So we applied logic to get a list
of potential predictor variables.
Then we made sure that there were no
duplicate variables, and now the last
thing we want to do is check
correlations between our variables.
Correlation is a measure of
association between two variables.
In layman's terms,
this means if one variable moves,
does another variable move in parallel?
The correlation coefficient
values range from -1 to 1,
with 1 being a total
positive correlation,
zero having no correlation and
-1 having total negative correlation.
Going a little further, figuring
this out can tell us two things.
The first thing would be what may be
a good quality predictor variable.
And the second thing being determining
if there's inner correlation
between our predictor variables.
So correlation is measured using
different types of association, Pearson,
Spearman or Hoeffding's.
In this course, we'll be using Pearson
by default, yet more can be read on
the differences between the correlation
types in the reading notes.
Let's now take a look at our data and
the correlation measure through Pearson
association plus their corresponding
scatter plots over on Alteryx.